so most of my audience probably realizes
by now that the undocumented immigration
us-mexico border situation is definitely
not a crisis it's definitely not a
national emergency
that doesn't mean national emergencies
don't exist what is an actual emergency
is yet another one of these measles
outbreaks this one in Washington State
caused by parents choosing not to
vaccinate their children I recently told
you two weeks ago about the anti-vaccine
movement being listed as one of the top
ten global health threats in 2019 by the
World Health Organization this is a
major major problem in many parts of the
world we now have a mini measles
outbreak in Washington state where 36
cases are reported so far and the
governor has declared a public health
emergency in the state almost every
single one of those 36 cases 35 actually
are kids under 10 most of whom have not
been vaccinated plus one adult case that
makes up the 36 now you might say well
our 36 cases really an emergency it
seems like a small number in a state
that has a population of millions well
the reason it's an emergency there's
actually a couple reasons why it's an
emergency number one this is optional
and it's happening because parents are
choosing not to vaccinate their kids so
there's the concern that as if I guess I
would say if non vaccination grows in
popularity the spread can become
exponentially greater because measles is
highly contagious it can kill small
children and again all but one of the
cases as of a few hours ago are kids
under 10 and the spread has taken place
in just about 10 days you can catch
measles by going into a room hours after
someone with measles has left the room
so imagine the chaos that this can cause
in public health care facilities in
schools in community centers in retail
stores where people have been touching
iPads and mobile phones or whatever else
they go in to look at also there's a
question of what happens to also be
taking place in Washington states in
Washington State it's much easier to get
these opt-out exemptions from vaccines
for kids that are going to public
schools in a lot of these counties in
Washington State also in Oregon it's a
problem the opt-out rate for
vaccinations is getting close to 10% in
some places 7.5% in some others these
are the non-medical exemptions okay
sometimes people can't get vaccines
because of medical conditions a number
of different conditions which I don't
have to list today that's not what I'm
talking about here and because of how
herd immunity works and the reality that
not everybody can get vaccinated when
your non-medical opt-out rate starts to
get to seven eight nine ten percent you
are going to significantly exacerbate
the spread of disease period most of
these cases could have been prevented
not all right no vaccine is 100 percent
but the way the math works this is an
optional outbreak and the real people
who lose in these cases Pat are the kids
a we we have to realize the parents more
than likely are vaccinated they have
made the decision not to vaccinate their
children measles is far less deadly for
adults than for kids so this is an
actual emergency the us-mexico border
not actually an emergency yeah whenever
a child comes down with a serious
disease it's tragic but this is even
more tragic in some sense because it's
totally preventable we already have the
medicine we already have the discoveries
this doesn't have to happen in the same
way it's kind of like gun violence right
we know how to cut down on the number of
mass shootings we know that fewer guns
means less crime and yet we still have
to deal with the problem because we just
can't convince some people that we have
the right way to approach it
it's it's the same here and it's really
unfortunate so what can we do what are
at least options for what could be done
number one it should be really difficult
to get non-medical exemptions for
vaccines if you want to put your kid in
a public school okay that that's it just
it needs to be much harder and there are
laws in a lot of states in the works
some have already passed them some are
discussing them to make it much more
difficult to get non-medically related
exemptions from vaccination for children
who are going to public school if your
homeschooling as unfortunately lots of
anti-vaxxers do fortunately or
unfortunately depending on your approach
do whatever you want right I don't know
a legal framework where the government
would force vaccination but as a
requirement for public school attendance
it should not be easy to get a
non-medical exemption other ideas that
have been floated and it's unclear
whether these could really be made
realities insurance companies could look
at whether they are going to pay for
treatment coming from non-medical VAG's
vaccine exemptions right so if you chose
not to vaccinate your kid for measles
and there was no medically relevant
reason to do that could insurance
companies consider limiting how much
they are going to reimburse in those
cases is that a door we would want to
open I don't know I'm just telling you
it's an option that's being discussed I
read one idea of looking at whether
optional non vaccination should be
considered a type of neglect by state
child services although that's a very
tough hill to climb and there are
probably some slippery slope questions
there that are not unconcerned with
everything that we're dealing with
climate change our political system
subjugated by corporate interests and
wealthy people media consolidation and
takeover immoral wealth inequality we
have parents causing a problem because
they just don't want to vaccinate their
kids it's absolutely pathetic and now we
actually have a public health emergency
in the state of Washington truly truly
disgusting one of the day's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy comm
icon I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter
because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link